[Musique]
l'histoire
sais pas
mais je sais
c'est très marrant de bon matin ce
jour-là pharaons s'adresse à sa main
d'oeuvre enfin main d'oeuvre parce qu'en
fait c'était pas vraiment les esclaves
historiquement parlant mais bon donc il
faut dire mende mais bon on n'est pas
dupe
en
dessous et parra
je vous annonce que la plus grande
pyramides d'égypte est terminée
c'est pourquoi nous allons construire
une encore plus grain
des questions quand vous dites nous
allons construire vous allez nous aider
au mourre d'esclaves d'autres questions
pourquoi est ce qu'on construit des
pyramides
un bien sûr on pourra choisir nos
équipes ouais c'est vrai c'est sympa
aller en compte d'autres questions oui
moi je me demandais hockey mes
ingénieurs en d'estimé pour réaliser
cette construction il faudrait 40 et 50
de travail et à environ 160 mille blocs
de granit et pour vous faire porter le
granit
875 millions de poids à mais bien sûr
des milliers d'entre vous vend vous
rires écrasé par le sperme ou dans
d'horribles souffrances notre
subissaient les atroces morsure du
soleil mais quoi vous êtes des esclaves
où vous êtes de moquette vous et aidez
est des esclaves
voilà alors vous êtes contents
[Musique]
non mes frères rebelles on nous formons
yves le foll
mais non non non rebelles on ou mama
mama mains vives moyens le pharaon mais
non mais plus beaucoup plus rebelle en
ou plus au mama maman ben c'est vrai que
sociologiquement parlant d'un régime
bancal mais ya des points positifs
j moyens le pharaon
vive youpi le fao
et on n'a rien dit de mal là désolé j'ai
été pris par le rythme et c'est ainsi
que fut entrepris la construction de la
plus grande pyramide de l'histoire et
que fut inventée l'ancêtre de la caisse
claire de disco show
[Musique]